we have something in common which is we
both used to work at nbc
when i was doing late night i'm told
that you worked there in the building at
30 rock what were you doing there
i was an editor for the local news so i
worked at wnbc
and i worked the overnight shift um
because
i was easy to get along with i was tipsy
all the time and
it was like a midnight to 9 30 a.m shift
so i would do stand-up
at night do a couple of shows barking
and people free comedy show all that
stuff and then
go to 30 rock and sometimes
ooh now i'm spilling the tea sometimes i
would bring comedians back with me
because
back then security wasn't what it is now
you know
before like 9 11 and stuff
so i would bring communities with me and
i would take them to your set
oh pictures yes like
so you'd come you know so you would come
to the late night set to my set
and you guys would hang out there like
at the desk and the chair and all that
no it wasn't like the bleachers and
fight night lights
we weren't like alex conan's stuff like
we respected your space but we're not
just like
we never sat in your chair okay in the
host chair
you could have easily done that because
i'll tell you my secret which is when i
was a writer on soundoutlive
in my 20s i sometimes used to wander the
building at night and i would go down to
david letterman's
studio which later became my studio and
i'd sit in his chair
and yeah i wasn't i didn't have any i i
know you're showing me a lot more
respect than i show dave and i
admire him greatly so i just thought a
chair is a chair and i would sit down
and sometimes work on a sketch
sitting at dave's late night chair at
like two in the morning
when i was staying up all night so that
is bold but i guess you did get the juju
maybe i should have sat in your chair
if you had sat in my chair you'd have
taken that job for me immediately
it was so inspiring to just be one floor
away
and see what could have been i remember
working late night shifts and then also
just
watching your show and watching um greg
geraldo and todd lin
and all these amazing stand-ups and just
thinking okay keep writing your jokes in
between like the house fires that you
have to edit
but even back then in my 20s i was like
i love
being a part of a production but i can't
work in the edit bay i'm too cute not to
have a window you know
exactly your beauty is wasted in an edit
room you that's why i'm so glad you got
out of there
it's important that you got out of there
thank you